[Music]
unrelated news
so really submitted by I love LA oh you
also don't live here I love LA and I
like grew up here I like the food in LA
cuz you're a second tomatoes yeah but
[ __ ] the traffic here this [ __ ] city
a newly sworn-in sheriff was suspended
after it was discovered she had
previously been a dominatrix in bondage
spell that's awesome oh that's so dumb
why would they do that I mean she
already has experience with handcuffs
all right
was she a sworn in deputy or sworn in
sure she was finishing her Academy
deputy then oh she's just deputy okay so
it's just like a low-level police
officer but what does that have to do
with her being a cop exactly right so
that's why if she passed Academy if
she's doing all the things right who
cares she used to whip people in the
butt not like it was a criminal
activities you know that means the
people that doing the background checks
they [ __ ] up yep because they're not
even supposed to go to the Academy until
after they clear the backgrounds so that
means they were still doing the
background while she was in the Academy
that just means that one of the deputies
was jacking off to her porno and then
they go oh my god that's [ __ ] deputy
Anderson or whatever that seems more
likely oh this all takes place in New
Jersey but yeah so other thing is that
six days before her graduation from the
Academy the County Sheriff's Office
ended up suspending her and they were
saying that they're suspending her to
protect the integrity of the department
to prevent her from taking an oath of
office for which she is not entitled to
what's wrong with being a dominatrix
they make it seem like she was a drug
dealer or something well I guess the
reason why they're so far bothered by it
is one because the department was
getting made fun of - oh no the tests
had those the job ha ha ha ha ha yeah
they're saying that they're being
objective inquiry and ridicule among law
enforcement critics ionic bonds I
wanna be bullied anymore yeah so pretty
much when they go to the police
basketball game everyone's climbing on
them and they can't handle it that
sounds like walking reading [ __ ] to me
yeah oh my god another one of the
reasons is because she failed to
disclose her baggage past what is dead
of this close is nothing illegal yeah
that's her point her and her lawyers
points like she didn't do anything you
leave me like I used to be an arm
wrestling champion I didn't feel like I
have to reveal that but I gotta deal
with anything they ask you like if
you've had any thank you illegal ask
you've done what illegal activities no
it's pretty [ __ ] funny though I just
pictured one of the guys he goes I went
out the door witness like pants around
his ankles and hold on did you run as
[ __ ] oh people jacket off wait you
can't even put you walk into the room
like this guys that's what I'm picturing
right now this is ridiculous
well another thing too that she failed
to discloses that she would see clients
privately for money but they're still
saying like but that wasn't illegal so
yes that's not illegal it's not illegal
to get paid to beat someone's ass yeah
she was also saying that in the film
says she worked in she got paid at that
time for those films but even now that
they're being distributed online like
she has no control over that and she's
not getting money from the video views'
now that sucks
she should have got residuals yeah
exactly she needed to explain like her
in a USC fighter can pay the people what
was it yep
yeah and she's also saying that in these
films she never used her real name she
was never naked in any of them she never
did any sexual act she's got class
that's not what the dominators is for
right they just beat the [ __ ] out of you
yeah yeah or like teach you like a slave
or something like that or what lady
coppers this is Kristin I actually think
it's great because she has no like she's
not scared to beat down a dude or a bad
guy or whatever take them down and cuff
them or whatever yeah so I feel like
that's cool she right when this is
happening the guys coming out with his
pants are on his ankle this look like
picture
you're tired if you bust through the
door today if you know after watching
this has exactly my picture I have a
discovery
let me trash my brother I just came yeah
but hours before the graduation is when
they decided to let her graduate but it
was literally that same date was when
they were like okay we'll let you
everyone's thinking I wish you'll beat
my ass yeah that's that doesn't sure the
dominatrix whoo she's hot that's still
part of me oh my oh yeah she's really
like the leather
oh he's kicking his balls my god I could
see why it's pretty funny though and
Holly we really feel them special arias
but did you put a badge category if you
put a badge on her now she's just a
pulse he's just a lot to remember
beating the crap out of like a bunch of
like KKK naked people that she lets see
this video she's like covered up too
because the girl behind her she's doing
latex but it's like see-through leap I
know she looks like a condom she did she
just looks like he's in a wetsuit
[ __ ] choking awesome body at that
that she's freaking pretty I wonder if
we would get in trouble like let's say
Jay King who shuts down and we have to
be cost I wonder if we could be caught I
don't think though we have so many
[ __ ] opinions on up there naturally
she could think you guys have been
people think you guys are seriously
you're really being sarcastic I feel
like the regular beat cops or whatever
they're just you have to be a standard
robot but then the more high level you
become or undercover or whatever then
you can probably do a lot of crazy [ __ ]
but I think when you're a part of an
organization - they don't want you to
have your own opinions they don't want
you to be a thinker or anything like
that and they don't want you to talk
about pedophilia
I just like kids shut up I'm saying that
she's sound weird but that's my honest
shot I feel like cops are all good as
comedians but what sucks is that like
what they have to show and what who they
are in real life are two different
things
you have to be professional so like
after this uniform on you have to like
uphold this [ __ ] but everyone's a human
being
but I know like some really funny cops
with a really good sense of humor but
they can't be that some cops don't have
a sense of humor though I was getting a
Jersey Mike's cookie we're talking my
sandwiches like last week
and so I got like my sandwich that I
wanted it's like a ghost at cops you
don't see a lot of like he was like a
bodybuilder right and I was just kind of
shot at whoa right and he is right so
what's the world for us like you should
really kill you like you choked the [ __ ]
out of somebody he decide
move along pup is sick all right guess
I'm not that funny I got myself I want
the [ __ ] out okay all right
you're kind of an [ __ ] it's probably
like thinking like you think we all just
beat people all day know is just look
your [ __ ] arms are the same size as
your chest bro like what the [ __ ] he
isn't sleeve a full uniform and his
shirt was like you was gonna care
another my god I just shot the book I've
never seen a caught that buff before you
mean they do steroid testing in the
police academy I mean oh absolutely I
have a source when he worked the jail
systems because the prisoners were
getting so big that if you worked out
off [ __ ]
they would pay you overtime pages for
you to work out and they were passing
steroids amongst each other Wow because
they just they just needed it like the
people because the people in jail are
taking steroids and they're working out
and they're getting [ __ ] jab you do
you can't have a puny ass cop trying to
take down like a 250 pound doesn't move
so they were actually passing steroids
around that's crazy
he might be tickets to it because like I
was Jai [ __ ] Norma's if I become an
officer I want to be one of those guys
that are like always getting in trouble
by the department and then there's you
know like in the movies like they're
like you're the renegade one with the
own future all rules give me your badge
and then like I give them the badge but
then like I'm still doing police work
because I still have honor yeah and like
I find out that there's corruption
inside the police off like Department
and everyone's against me and they think
I'm a kook but then actually like I
saved the day that's the kind of cop I
want to be longest description of China
that just it's weird like how much
respect a cops demand though because
when I got my sandwich it was like what
do you want and I was like oh this is
you're like all right would you like
that Mike swear no cool and then what
right when the obstacle
in their life hello officer what would
you like how's your day oh well welcome
you can't talk to me like that well
because they're public employees that's
right like they I'm a big employer we
make people laugh
so it's like controversial for them
because they're saying like you know we
can't have this public employee with a
path like that like I wish you let
somebody they're dicks gonna be harder
[ __ ] I know the resistance I think I
think it's because like I said when you
do a government job or anything they
want you to be like not a human being
they just want you to represent and be a
part of whatever like institutional yeah
well not that it's just you have to be
this picture-perfect cutter yeah ding
you're a robot basically a standardized
robot I don't know the difference
between a football player and a
dominatrix it's a huge difference in
terms of like in the public eye that
looks like anything in the sex work
realm is art because sex is just not
accepted here everyone wants to [ __ ] the
football player but because he's skilled
at football not because he's selling any
sort of sex do not I mean everyone wants
to [ __ ] the dominatrix cause because I'm
totally in this sector you if I was
pulled over by this cop right and I
recognized her face for sure I'm
thinking lewd things for sure like if I
I'm you know just being honest like if I
look over my so you would agree then in
this no I think she should still have a
job for sure I would be thinking of her
naked but I think that's even better
because now your cards are down oh for
sure this is it a rat holes open and we
are not wanting to get hard and then now
like you're not going to fight her at
all so you guys aren't so we know that
you guys aren't like the majority in
terms of thought you guys are really
open-minded but for the masses who are
religious who do see sex I was like a
thing that should be kept like PDA is
still looked down upon you never send
the working on the matrix in the Bible
or the Quran of course so because it's
not in there it's looked down upon
so proving my point I think that she
would be great as one of the Kings
guards which came the stones oh yeah my
My Kingdom don't other countries have
that would have like really hot
assassins because they know sex is like
distract
China weren't they using like spices
gaddafi he had a team of bodyguards of
naked women
Amazonian women so they should promote
her to the zero service they're all
military women but they weren't hot I
mean there's some of them are like
average but they're actual military
women like and in some of them or
glammed-out like they had their hair
done and all that that's smart yeah all
right
you're stupid yeah I think he's great
how's it going guys
don't forget to like the video because
if you don't I will break your [ __ ]
legs thank you so much for the last
video don't forget to click right here
or I'll break your [ __ ] arms click
right here guys
[Music]